Mình tạm thả tâm, con đôi hàng của bạm Mỹ bắt đầu cuộc tập trận quân sự chung thường liên
mong tên UG là chẳng tự do kéo dạng về một ngày.
Cô tập trận thường liên nhằm tăng cường khả năng phó thu chung, trước các mối đe dọa tại mạnh đào chương tiên.
Mặc dù viên hàng của bận cửa khoảng 18.000 bình tham gia giống năng ngoái,
tuy nhiên trong năng này, khoảng 2 người trong số đủ mới bản phẩm lưới thực lier đã được mắn lại sẵn tham sau.
Chuyên quyết xe 1 tuyên mũ đồng thả kéo dãng quy mù tập trận là nhằm dạm càng thẳng liên châu.
Đây là của tập trận lâu tiên giới thời tổng thống liên giang mông người nhận trước thẳng chiến và cỏ chính sách của phục quân hệ và lòng tin với bình yếu.
Trong cuộc họp nội các người mẹ tạm thẳng tâm, ông li cũng yêu cầu từ kiện tương phần các thỏ thật liên chyều hiện có.
Mắt đầu từ những phỏ thận có thể thực hiện được nhằm dạm càng thẳng giữa hai miền.
Trong đó, chỉ quyền cũng li cũng đã tạm dân có hoạt động truyền chuyển trong trường tiên bao gồm việc nguyên phát loa phòng thành tại biến giới và phát sống đàn án nhằm đạo điều kiện cho phục quân thuộc tội thuại.
Tuy nhiên, trong tiên đã bắt bỏ khăn lực này và kým cho trong em gái của lãnh đạo kým cho nương,
gọi các sẵn kiến hoặc biên của xe 1 là giất mơ viện vông và tuyên bố không quan tâm đến phục quân thuại của hành quốc.